moi je suis blanc
un bon gros babtou
et parmi le blanc je suis très très blanc
c'est a dire que moi quand je prend une photo la nuit avec le flash je reflète la lumiere
on dirait un panneau de circulation (bruit de klaxon)
parfois quand je fais une photo de moi sur instagram et que je met un filtre , et bas je disparais de la photo
c'est ... c'est un peu relou , c'est a dire que moi on vois mes veines a travers ma peau
quand je montre mon muscle on dirait un raviolis chinois
ouai je suis blanc et alors ,moi quand j'envois un texto
euh j'envoi le smiley  pouce blanc
celui qui est le plus blanc possible
moi avec ma peau je bronze jamais
ou alors même si jamais je bronze après des milliers d'heures d'exposition au soleil
heu sa se voit a peine
gars au téléphone ; ouai donc ouai livraison c'est
norman : salut les mec
gars au téléphone : oh norman tu pars en vacance  la
tu pars ou
norman : ah ba non je revient . J'étais pendant un mois sous le soleil des caraïbes
(ils reprennent leurs travails)
comme je craint a mort les rayon du soleil , heu quand  je suis a la piscine extérieur je dois porter un t-shirt
moi je suis le seul boloss qui fait ses longueur avec un t-shirt
( norman nage )
( le maitre nageur observe la piscine )
le maitre nageur : mais il est en train de se noyer la
le maitre nageur: monsieur vous êtes tombé a l'eau tout habillé
norman : mais non je
le maitre nageur :c'est bon  sa va allez  je vais vous sauver
mais non c juste mon t-shirt je me baigne comme sa , je sais nager pu****
les blague entre communauté il faut pas trop en abusé hein sa peu être un peu  gênant
moi heu en tant que gros blanc au yeux bleu j'ai souvent le droit a :
alors toi t'es blond au yeux bleu un aria quoi le.. le nazi
merci c'est vraiment sympa d'être associé a un des mouvements les plus exterminateur du monde
c'est ...c'est vraiment flatteur
il y a des truc  qui vont moins bien au blanc . Je sais pas un renoi ou un métisse avec le crane rasé
c'est tout de suite un peu hip hop tu vois
moi je pourrais jamais avoir le crane rasé c'est sur
(norman chante )
l'homme : oh salut norman sa va mon gars
norman : sa va et toi
l'homme : pu*** je savait pas pour ton cancer
Norman : j'ai pas de cancer
c..c'est un nouveau style que je me suis donné j...je fais un peu hip hop
l'homme : même avec ta chimiothérapie tu garde ton humour  sa c'est bien sa
Norman : n'importe quoi hey ...heu  c'est ... il y a pas de chimiothérapie
Norman : hey c'est mon nouveau style  O.K
l'homme : profite des dernier jours
D'ailleur a se propos  , j'ai découvert un truc plutôt flippant en allant chez le dermato
voila moi j'ai un max de grain de beauté partout comme beaucoup de blanc
sauf que le dermato m'a expliqué la vrai nature , en faite des grain de beauté
docteur : bon bah Norman j'ai compté , vous avez 341 grain de beauté
Norman: 341 !! pff génial
docteur : hein  hein c'est ça. donc 341 mini cancer inoffensif
ouai donc on disait ...
Norman : ah,  bah moi je vais y allez, hein de toute façon j'avais piscine
je vais aller heu nager évidement avec un t-shirt  hein
nous les blanc on est aussi parfois victime de cliché
hein comme ce cliché qui dit que les blanc ne savent pas danser heu c'est n'importe quoi
(il danse sur de la musique techno)
bon ok c'est vrai on sait pas très bien danser
surtout ...surtout moi
pff c'est nul ces clichés
, c'est comme moi j'entend dire les noir sont au meilleur coup au lit que les blanc
n'importe quoi
attend moi je suis blanc et je te cache pas que parfois je me suis fait un peu complimenter
si tu vois se que je veux dire
les deux : aahhhh
la fille : bébé pu**** je sais pas se que tu avais ce soir mais c'était trop trop bien quoi
Norman : je te remercie
moi j'ai la chance d'avoir pas mal de potes issue de la diversité
et j'ai l'impression que certaine ethnie qui sont quand même plus chaleureuse que d'autre
je sais pas des fois quand un  renoi croise un autre renoi inconnu on dirait qu'il sont méga pote depuis des années
homme de droite : excuse moi excuse moi , est ce que tu sais ou est la rue st Denis
homme de gauche : ouai tout droit sur la gauche frère
homme de droite : merci pu**** tu assurre
alors que quand un blanc croise un autre blanc inconnu
heu c'est pas pareil
Norman : bonjour
l'homme :bonjour
norman : tu vas bien
l'homme : ah on se tutoie direct carrément
Norman : bah attend , on est voisin depuis 2 ans on peut quand même se tutoyé
l'homme : s'il vous plait agression au 3 eme s'il vous plait
( vacarme)
l'homme : il est très agressif s'il vous plait dépechez vous
mais bon voila je suis blanc très blanc
et alors c'est comme sa rien n'y personne ne pourra m'empecher de kiffer la vie
même pas les coup de soleil
le maitre nageur : hey monsieur vous craigniez rien la il n'y a plus de soleil
Norman : on sait jamais
yeah pouce de babtou